the world has ended the sky has fallen
doomsday has come and gone
so now what
well let's start rebuilding civilization
of course
how would you begin to come back from an
apocalypse
what could you use from the remains of
our old Society
and how would you be able to remember
anything
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we had to rebuild Human
Society from scratch
while you might be wondering how exactly
the world ended well that's not so
important it could have been a deadly
virus a massive asteroid Collision or a
nuclear war
or it could have been all of the above
what's more important is that you are
among the lucky survivors of this
doomsday scenario
but you would have lost a few things
that were essential to the life you led
before
the internet and computers no longer
work
libraries and databases have been
destroyed and many of our world's
knowledge Keepers like scientists
engineers and doctors have tragically
perished but you wouldn't have much time
to mourn if you wanted to keep the torch
of humanity lit through these terrible
times you'd need to focus on what you
could do with all the other survivors to
well survive and to start rebuilding
Society you'd really only need three
essential things
in his book the knowledge how to rebuild
our world from scratch
astrobiologist Louis dartnell says that
even though there have been many things
vital to our society's development there
are three Essentials that stand out
Above All Else
food
fire and knowledge
you'd need to figure out how to ensure
everyone gets the food and nutrients
they need to survive you'd have to
harness sources of power to make tools
and fuel transportation and lastly you'd
want to share and record that knowledge
so your society's future could continue
to thrive
and while you might consider yourself a
smart cookie with a sense of rugged
individualism you wouldn't be
knowledgeable enough to rebuild things
on your own
you'd need the collective wisdom and
strength of everyone around you and be
ready to ask questions and explore
outcomes
step one two rebuilding society would
involve the most important thing
Staying Alive
in the beginning you'd have to get by
with no power no antibiotics and none of
the Comforts of our modern world
during this period of time people would
need clean water shelter and fire for
warmth
don't already know how to take care of
these things
better find some people who do
ASAP
step two would rely on Scavenging what
remains of societies to find things that
could be useful to you and others
first and foremost that would mean going
through supermarkets for anything with a
long shelf life of course this wouldn't
be a long-term solution but it would at
least tide you over and keep your
stomach growling to a minimum
growing a wide variety of foods would be
an essential Next Step
and then of course you'd want a way of
preserving them
grains like wheat rice and corn have
been some of the most important crops in
human history they grow fast and fill us
up put the focus on them first
you'd need to develop Technologies to
grind grain into flour similar to the
ancient Roman water wheel or medieval
windmill
otherwise you'd be stuck doing it all by
hand
hopefully it wouldn't take you and your
community too long to figure out
something that works then you'd finally
be able to concentrate on more complex
things like power sources other than
fire
after years of rebuilding the basics it
may be tempting to think you could pick
up exactly where modern society left off
by burning fossil fuels
but you'd find that we've already used
so much of these resources up they would
no longer be so easily accessible
you'd need to build extremely complex
drilling systems in very remote areas
and that wouldn't be so realistic after
an apocalypse
you'd likely be limited to burning
things and if you wanted to start any
large-scale industrial projects such as
making steel bricks or glass you'd need
to burn a lot of fuel
charcoal would probably be the best
available option charcoal Burns hot
hotter than cold
it's practically carbon neutral too so
this would be a relatively sustainable
model to rebuild your Society with
you could take a few lessons from Brazil
which is currently the largest charcoal
producer in the world
just take your Timber air dry it pile it
into a soil covered Mound and let it
smolder
if that's not sustainable enough for you
well I'm sorry to say that you wouldn't
be able to jump right into using
renewable energy
while it would seem nice to throw up a
bunch of solar panels and call it a day
these are made from Pure silicon and
silicon is sand processed in a
complicated manner you wouldn't be able
to replicate just yet
and then there'd be possibly the most
important step of all
communication
connection is vital for human beings
you'd need to find and talk to other
survivors in order to save the human
race as a whole
now on a small scale you could
communicate with your local community by
teaching people and inspiring them
stories are a great way to retain
information
a well-told story could make it 20 times
easier to remember important facts
but to find survivors beyond your
immediate surroundings basic technology
like a radio would be vital
this could seem simple but it would be
even more complex than building a
toaster from scratch
if you managed to figure that out the
next challenge would be communicating
messages
this is where something like Morse code
would come into play
but there's a good chance you'd have to
learn that from scratch
the upside is that even if the people
receiving the message can't understand
it right away they at least know there
are others out there
once you established contact with other
communities you could start trading with
them you could share resources and
information and that would improve both
communities ability to survive
piece by piece you'd be on the road to
rebuilding society and who knows maybe
you'd be off to a better start
since you'd be using the power of your
collective intelligence and will to
survive
or maybe you'd like to see how well
you'd fare if you were the only person
left on Earth
but that's a story
for another
[Music]